Speaker 1: That's too bad. All right. Let's go
to our friend John Paul Jones.
John Paul Jones, welcome back.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Thank you for having me
on. I have three questions in an apology and serve
apology two or so. My first question is, have you
have you been thinking about going on Chris Kyle
in France? Second question I want to ask. As you
know, there was an article why there's about a
month and a half ago about how Biden doesn't think
he has enough France for Vladimir Putin in the war
Ukraine. I have if you and Biden shows a lot of
friends, would you be willing to give Putin? And
third, I. I started I started with a progressive
blog about three months ago. I've already posted
my first two articles. If I were to send them to
you on Twitter, would you be willing to read them?
And finally, I just want to apologize for
my behavior and the previous two calls. I
understand. I haven't been the best caller.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God, I don't. So let's see.
So let's go. Reverse order. I don't remember
your previous calls, so no need to apologize
to if you send me articles on Twitter. I can't
even look at my Twitter feed. It's so over, it's
so overloaded. So I basically just look at the
verified feed. I know that that's very elitist
of me, but I just it's it's impossible to see
anything. I get so many messages and I'm honestly
just too busy to be reviewing other people's
projects right now. Number two, if I was on hold,
if I was in Biden's shoes, I guess going in
reverse order, we're now in number three. But
if I was in Biden's shoes, what sort of an off
ramp could I imagine for Putin? I've talked about
this before. It's probably something where he gets
to stay in some of the regions he's already in,
like the Donetsk and Luhansk or
something. I don't know. I mean,
I don't love saying that, but it's probably
the type of off ramp that he needs. And
then what was the first question?
Speaker 3: Have you been think about
going on Christopher Kyle's friends?
Speaker 1: Oh, no, no. I mean, listen,
I can't. It's not. They would have to invite me.
It's not. Have I been thinking? It's not. It's not
up to me. They'd have to invite me, you know.
Speaker 3: Okay. Well, I mean, do you know of
any other progressive YouTubers that I
know that could offer me some advice?
Speaker 1: Advice. What you want
advice from progressive YouTubers.
Speaker 3: I'm starting a progressive blog.
Speaker 1: You know, rather than look for.
I would just start the blog, just start the blog
and grow the blog rather than getting advice from
people. The advice is just do it. Do it as well as
you possibly can. If you build it, they will come.
Speaker 3: Okay. Well. Thank you, David. I just
want to ask you, can I just wet and wet you now
and know who I'm named after?
Speaker 1: I'm guessing you're named
after the basis for Led Zeppelin.
Right. I mean, John Paul Jones.
Speaker 3: Actually, no. The thing I'm actually
named after my name comes from the founder of the
American Navy, John Paul Jones.
Speaker 1: Got it. Okay.
Speaker 3: All right. Well, thank you,
John Paul. Okay. Well, once again,
I'm sorry for my previous two calls.
Speaker 1: Apology unnecessary. I
have no memory of the calls. There is
John Paul Jones. What a phone call.